les consommateurs ont été au rendez vous
durant la pandémie
moi j'ai consommé plus mal fait de ne
pas travailler d'être à la maison
au début j'étais pendant qu'ils vont
fermer le magasin donc j'ai commandé
beaucoup
statistique canada indique qu'avant la
pandémie soit en février l'industrie du
cannabis a vendu pour 151,1 millions
neuf cent trente mille dollars
on met les ventes ont bondi de 22%
totalisant 185 millions huit cent
quatre-vingt dix sept mille dollars au
début de la pandémie en neurones
remarquer gauche au niveau des ventes en
écosse kursaal et maintenant on est
revenu à des niveaux qui sont plus
comparables avant la pandémie se peut
que ça lui n'est pas positif avec les
ventes de produits cannabis mais c'est
pas nécessairement la seule explication
l'industrie est en forte croissance
depuis la légalisation comparé à l'année
précédente c'est sûr qu'on voit que les
bombes sont vraiment augmenté ils ont
plus que doublé avec une augmentation de
116 % passant de 86 millions de dollars
en mai 2019 à 186 millions à la même
date en 2020 et l'offre augmente partout
au pays
en octobre 2010 nous avions 12
succursales et il ya 45 kursaal canopy
grotte possède 50 succursales
principalement dans l'ouest du pays pour
l'alberta
elle attribue en partie la hausse des
ventes aux nouvelles tendances d'achat 7
à cause des consommateurs qui vise
emmagasiné puis entreposés un peu de
cannabis extra qui c'est aussi à cause
de l'émergence en fait des gros sacs de
potes on vend plus de sacs de cannabis
qui contient 28 grammes de cannabis pour
ce psychiatre il y a eu plus d'achats
oui mais pas nécessairement plus de
consommation 6 % des gens qui auraient
rapporté une augmentation de leur
consommation de cannabis durant la
pandémie donc il faut se rappeler que 95
% des canadiens
finalement pour changer leur
consommation de cannabis mais ce sont
des consommateurs prévoyant ils auront
le nécessaire s'ils doivent se
recombiner ici marie josée paquet comme
ou radio canada montréal